well tough US sanctions on Iran are back
in effect this morning Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo said yesterday the
measures targeting oil shipping and
financial industries are the toughest
ever sanctions on Iran they are being
reinstated as part of the Trump
administration's withdrawal from the
2015 nuclear deal Elizabeth Palmer is in
Tehran with Iran's reaction good morning
Iran's normally moderate president
Hassan rouhani has come out swinging he
said that it's time to implement the
phrase death to America and put pressure
on the u.s. so it's afraid the
government further signaled its defiance
by broadcasting pictures of
anti-aircraft military exercises and
yesterday at an anti u.s. rally the head
of Iran's Revolutionary Guard warned
that America would threaten Iran at its
peril some in the crowd were toeing the
party line but many were just going
through the motions in fact few in this
country believe their government has the
skill or the political will to get them
out of this mess this morning so far
anyway the Iranian currency the rial is
stable but everybody expects that the
worst is yet to come
Nora all right Elizabeth Palmer in
Tehran thank you